[Music]  uh  [Music]  [Music]  ah  [Music]  don't worry  feet  hey the name skippy ring any bells fits  in a holster  more than a little psycho you  have skip little bastard got swiped a  while back  let me see him  let's see how you're doing run  diagnostics  performance 82 memory  damaged mode stone cold killer  hmm i better do a full scan at least it  still works  wait where'd you get this iron anyway  yeah knew a guy everyone called him  danish  great techie i mean before he started  hitting a bottle  anyway poker game danish cleaned out his  credit chip then bet his gun  i think you can put together the rest  the combat features are great  but why the voice interface you know  weird as hell  so something for my trouble  sure here you go it feels kind of weird  now  it's too quiet huh  maybe you should get a dog maybe someday  see reggie